Good afternoon everyone. I'm the
chief committee officer for
the library of Congress and
welcome to the library of
awesome I'm
not sure you can tell I'm
completely nerding out here.
So, if you're feeling
awesome I need all of you to do
that
big wonder woman pose. I
know for 40 years you've been
watching
our special guest tonight.
I'm not the only person that
was
twirling around when I was
a kid to think you were going to
turn
into a wonderful. We want
to thank you again for
participating
again. It's a big deal we
have our special guest here and
a big
deal that our collection
ask on display. The library has
one of
the largest comic book
collections in the world. We
have a
amazing pop up
exhibit. Wonder woman appeared
by DC and a treat
to see. If tease your first
time at the library, feast your
eyes
to the ceiling and
Instagram like crazy.
Also, I mean, if
you're having fun now, there's
more fun
events coming -- a couple
of weeks we're starting the
first
outdoor film series, it
will run for six consecutive
Thursdays,
amazing movie that's you
will remember growing up with,
like top
gun, Raiders of the lost
arc, please have your lawn
chairs ready.
Let's talk about
what's happening here today. We
want to
thank all the sponsors that
make this possible. We can't do
what
we do without Congress and
our special donors that make
these
programs happen. Let's talk
about Lynda Carter shall we?
>> » (APPLAUSE): .
For the -- for 40
something years I think when she
first
appeared on TV, I think all
of us identified as wonder
woman,
when you think of wonder
woman you think of her. For the
past 75
years, she's looking great
for being 75 -- we have a a
little
clip to show you how she
has changed through the years.
I'm delighted to be here with
you today at the United
Nations celebrate wonder
woman being named honorary am
bass door
for theem pourlett for
women and girls. I have some
familiarity
with wonder woman, and I
couldn't think of a more perfect
role
for her. More than 40 years
ago I had the honor of being
cast --
more than 40 years ago --
more than 40 years ago.
I was cast as wonder woman by
warner bros.
This was a
moneymen to us thing, at
the time there were very few
women show
showing their own shows in
television. They didn't think a
woman
could hold a television
show. We started getting letters
and
phone calls, I started hear
ing stories, this miracle of
idea that
came from a 48 year old
woman named Elizabeth, started
to have an
influence in some girl's
and woman's lives that's when
wonder
woman became flesh, this
idea became a reality, the she
became we
we, in some magical and
mystical way, their lies within
each of
us wonder woman. She is
real.
She lives and breaths
I know this because she lives in
me
and she lives in the
stories that these women tell me
day in and
day out, I see it in the
eyes that dance before me, I see
it in
the letters and in the
story, I read it on social media
, I see it
in the tears that fall from
the eyes of the women who say
it's
saveed them some, it
inspireed them from some awful
thing that they
endured because they saw,
they saw that they could do
something
great.
You see, women really
know who they are.
We can be smart and
beautiful and strong and wise
and kind
and brave, we believe in
Fairplay, fair pay, and playing
by the
rules.
We build families and
communeityies and yes, we stand
by our
men. As they stand beside
us.
Wonder woman helps
bring out out the inner strength
every
woman has. We are all
inclusive that's who women are.
We are
stronger together.
We are half the world.
We have a voice. We are the
mothers
of all mankind. We are
mothers and sisters and daughter
s and
grandmothers and great
grandmothers, we are tall and
short and
thick and thin, we are
blonde and begin engineers and
salt and
peppers. All of you women
of all colors, all you children
out
there. Never forget the
wonder woman inside you. I see
these
beautiful faces, learn know
, be everything that you dream.
Ladies and gentlemen, your
wonder women, the one and only
Lynda Carter.
Oh, wow. Wow.
Wow.
Welcome to the library
of Congress.
This crowd is
wonderful. There's also an
overflow room too.
How did this make you
feel Mrs. Carter after 40 years?
Can I
call you Carla?
Oh yes, definitely. Or do I call
you doctor? No,
madam library. Madam.
That's a good one.
You know, it is --
it's really interesting that
after all
these years, that wonder
woman is come full circle and
she's
still so relevant. That
speech that you saw was given at
the UN,
and it was for women and
girls across the world.
And it was -- it was
about the idea of wonder woman.
When I said wonder
woman is real, it's the idea of
wonder
woman that is real because
she does live in us. It is the
idea of
that piece of us when
maybe no one believes in us or
we've been
bullyied or someone thinks
we are not tall enough or pretty
enough
for -- for good enough or
smart enough or enough, enough,
or we
have
obstacles to overcome where we
live in a nation that wants
to hide our faces or in an
area that does not have good
education
or the skin we live in is
not
an easy color to live in in our
neighborhood or in our
country.
I had a singer -- one
of my singers who is an amazing
person
said to me recently, she
said, you know Lynda, I -- I
can't
change this and living
inside this skin just became
harder for me
me.
What do you say to
that?
that? I say
I fight every day with you --
I say I fight every day
with you to help educate you,
help you
realize you know, I'm an
old girl now. But I will never,
and
until my dying day, I will
never stop fighting for the idea
of
wonder woman. The idea of
intellect and strength.
Intellect and
courage. Intellect what
this library is showing us,
gives us,
what Dr. Carla Hayden is
able to offer in a digitized
world.
At your fingertips, a resource,
so rich, so rich, that you
could access it at any time
, that's what I hope for you all
of
you. That's what if my life
means anything, and who knows
it can
go at any time. If my life
means anything, it's that I give
you
the gift of curiosity about
yourself, about the world
around you,
about tapping into your own
intellect and courage. That's
how I
feel about this.
Wow.
So Lynda, I'm ready to put on a
costume and go out and do
something -- okay? I don't
know about you but that's what
it
means, and even though --
and she's celebrating her 75th
birthday -- the come in
this case -- wonder woman
started in 1941
1941, and did you have any
trepidation with -- when they
said
would you like to embody
wonder woman in the 70's? Nope.
You said
I'm ready. I'm ready. No,
you have to understand the time
-- now,
I was in Hollywood during
the time when there were no
women in
television, they did not
think first of all, that a woman
could
hold a series, they did not
think women would tune in to
watch an
hour long with a woman as a
lead.
They also said, women are going
to hate you so just get
ready.
Go girl. Yeah.
They -- the only other
woman on the set was a script
supervisor, which is
basically the secretary of the
set, there
were the stunt person was a
man --
first time I got on the set
and this guy had chest
headquarters coming out the top.
Two
bullets here --
kind of walking like this -- I
said,
I said, oh
the camera is going to be
so far away you'll never tell.
I said,
I think this and this you're
going to tell -- and I
started, we started that
show started the students women
's
association.
>> » (APPLAUSE): Great
.
Women have to be doubleed by
women. From that point on.
And
just a fantastic mow men tus
wonder woman is directed by
my good friend Patty
Jenkins, she's a spit fire. Oh
my God, she's
amazing. If you haven't
seen it go see it.
In fact, -- in fact,
-- I didn't answer your question
--
when I got the part -- you
were ready -- I was ready, I
knew what
I wanted to do with the
character, I knew that if you
didn't want
to be her friend, if you
wanted to be her or be her best
friend,
any guy that looked at me
and with some girl I would bop
him
upside the head and say get
a grip.
Well I have to tell
you that director Patty -- see
-- we've
got a lot of energy up here
.
Because Patty Jenkins
tweeted this week a note from a
person
that works in a
kindergarten and talked about
the impact that a
the wonder woman had -- a
boy that was obsessed with iron
man had
asked his parents for a new
wonder woman lunch box. Good.
And the little girl
said when I grow up I want to
speak
hundreds of languages like
Diana. And another little girl
had her
revamp the beauty birthday
party in three days because she
simply
had to have a wonder woman
party and that's the impact and
the
note ended consider this
your friendly reminder that if
this
movie completely changed
the way these girls and boys
thought
about themselves in a world
in a week imagine what the next
we give them more movies like
wonder
woman. What do you think?
Yeah.
I -- I told Patty that I was not
going to see any --
we've spoken -- since the
day it was announceed that she
was going
to direct this film, we
spoke the next day, and we had
become
great, great, great friends
, and I was very free with with
my own
ideas, not about her film
but about the essence of the
character.
I never spoke to gal
about her character because it's
not
something you do with one
actress to another, but as gal
and I
were so insync about this
character, I told her that I did
not
want to -- I did not watch
any trailers, I did not read any
of
her interviews about her
process, I only spoke to her
directly. I
wanted to go to the
premiere which she invited me to
personally,
I wanted to go to the
premiere uncluttered.
And so, I went with my
family, my grown children and
my
husband, to the premiere,
and I -- my heart was pounding.
And and I was taken
aback because the essence of
that -- of
who that character is for
so many of us and for so long,
there's
a goodness, there's a heart
, it's about -- it's about
something.
It's about who we are as
people, as
against the violence, it's
about defending what's
right, it's about being
Massachusetts
bears, it's about those
things that we hold so dear.
And so, this is great.
And did you -- and
did you think about the fact
that you
would inspire generations
of girls and boys as you were
really
fighting on the set and
making sure things were going
the way
that you really thought
they should or did you know or
have a
sense? I really does
believe -- I had to fight for a
lot of
things -- they -- they
tried to stare me -- they
thought I was
too sweet in the beginning
so they tried to get me to be
more
assertive with my stuff and
, a couple of those episodes
that a
arose were real stingiers.
I can't watch them. But when I
-- when
I kind of stuck to my guns
and really wanted to, you know,
it's
like -- this is who she is
-- she -- you know, you're born
tall,
you can't make yourself
short. It's just who you are.
You're born
with what you're born with,
and these are the cards that
you're
dealt and those are her
cards, this is who we are and we
talked
about backstage, whatever
that is, and whatever age we are
, it's
what we are. I like being a
woman.
>> » (APPLAUSE): .
I like looking good.
You know?
And do I like being
older? Well, -- it's growing on
you -- I
guess so. I can't change it
. So I might as well embrace it.
You know, it is what
it is. And it's not exploitation
, you
know, it's -- you know,
we're going to do what we do.
Wear the
long earrings or not. If
you like to wear conservative
things
great, we're not competing
-- we're certainly not competing
guys. We are so thankful. I'm so
thankful.
For the men in my life
that have helped me on this
journey
-- I embrace every single
one of you. I embrace every
single one
of you who sits by my side,
who has helped me when I'm down
and I
need a you know a -- when I
went back to singing, someone
stole
all my music and my stuff,
I was going back on stage and my
son
-- my son -- six foot 5 and
mom, look at me --
if you go out
there and mess it up, we're
still going to love you -- you
know.
Things like that. You know,
these guys that support us, I'm
tired
of them being marJanuaryial
izeed. We own feminism. It's our
s. You
guys are not feminist. You
support us, and we support you,
and
come along for the ride.
Now we mentioned the new wonder
woman and it's the number
one movie everywhere.
How does that make you
feel? Wow, this is -- it lives
again.
I told Patty, that
before I saw the movie I said
this movie
is going to kill, this
movie is going to be great. She
was
nervous, you know. She just
made the best movie she could
make,
and that's all we can do,
is we go out there and we do the
best
damn job we can do, and
then the rest of it is the just
the rest
of it.
There are many element
that's we cannot control. So,
she
just put every effort into
if and she -- we talked an awful
lot,
and she's brilliant, she's
a brilliant director. You know,
women
can't make action movies
and women don't go to action
movies --
so, you know, boom, boom,
boom, and I said, this is going
to be
great. I said this movie is
going to gross over a a billion
dollars, there was silence
on the other end of the text,
just
silence and after the first
week it came in, I said what
did I
tell you? And she went,
yeah, maybe.
So, it's already done
like half a billion or 600
merchandise
merchandise, by the time
it's over -- which is good --
you want
people to go six and seven
times, you want it because it
just
gives her more opportunity
to do more things because I'm
sure she
didn't get paid nearly what
other direct fors have been
paid for
similar kinds of things but
that's Okay.
I think she will now.
Yeah.
>> » (APPLAUSE): .
Wow.
And if by chance I
they asked you to appear in a
sequel,
would you consider? She
asked me to do a came oin this,
she was
in England and I was doing
my concerts I went back to
singing --
it's how I started as a
singer, and I was at jazz
Lincoln center,
and at the Kennedy center
--
>> » (APPLAUSE): -- I
know -- and finishing up a new
album,
so at that time I just --
we couldn't -- we couldn't get
it --
our timing together, so
this next time if she writes me
a decent
part I might do it.
I think she will.
Because I have been
busy with your singing career,
you
mentioned that and I don't
know if a lot of people realize
that
you had a singing career
before and now you have a new
album
coming out. I do. I have a
new album, it's really kind of
eclectic, I have quite a
few original songs which I've --
I've
been writing a long time
but this past year nominated for
best
original music for a video
game --
>> » (APPLAUSE): .
And guess what else?
The library of Congress is in
the video
game.
I bet that's -- did you know
that? See, this is -- I mean,
this is very cool stuff,
comic stuffs and video games, I
mean,
who knew? I want to say one
thing -- we're talking about
wonder
woman which is all fine and
good but I had the great
opportunity
to meet the
13th librarian of Congress, Dr.
Billington, we were
at a state dinner and I sat
next to him and when I realize
ed who
he was, he -- his life's
work was digitizeing, the
beginning of
the emention work of
digitizeing this work of the
library, and how
he explained it was it's
not just putting things online,
it's
taking the original work,
not copies, which is what you
see
everywhere else, it's the
copies that you -- of the copies
of the
copies are quite degraded
by the time you get to try to
decipher
anything, so this was high
quality
digitizeing of the original
work. And I -- I was just
for a person with A DD which I
have,
could you tell?
Nope.
It is just a source -- I went
into the
Abigail letters and there's
blue things and you go I want
to see
what that is and you go
over here and over here and
pretty soon
I'm over to Abraham Lincoln
and I'm over here and over here
at
the civil war, it was like
just such a
treasure trove of
interesting learning almost
anything that you could
possibly want
to know. And seeing these
documents so clearly, and paint
ings and
architecture and anything
that you -- anything, and video
games
and comic books and you can
look up Lynda Carter.
And things are going
to come up.
And that's why we call
it the library of awesome and
we're
building on that legacy.
Dr. Billington and other library
ies of
Congress since 1802 and
it's just carrying the baton.
We're glad
you're here.
Only 14, only 14
librarians, only 14 -- and one
woman.
You can imagine.
So you can imagine how excited I
was -- I have to say --
wonder woman is coming? Oh
sure. I have so say what is
interesting about this, and
is that -- is this is just --
we're
half the world, as I said
we're half the world, we are the
mother
mothers of all man kind.
Hello?
This is about
-- it's -- if you're thinking
of a family, and
you're thinking you know,
we all agree that raise ago
family, you
really want to have two
parents, you want to have a
mother and a
father, you want to have a
father and a father or a mother
and
mother, whatever it is, but
you want to have co-parentsing
and you
want to have the I didn't
think and the yang -- why is it
that we
think that's not purposeful
and importance in our
government?
It's a supportive and another
point of view -- you know?
Went are much less about
hierarchy and more about commune
ity in
general.
That's maybe Anne over
statement, we don't ask how big
is it
it.
I couldn't help myself.
Lynda -- I couldn't help it.
Well,
I think it's time for question
and answer.
Because I have had the
-- I know I get myself in
trouble all
the time. It's okay, you're
wonder woman. I know I have had
the
opportunity to speak with
you and ask you some questions
and it's
just one before I open it
up and let everyone else -- have
you
had -- I know you've had
down times your life -- oh yeah,
was
there something that you
said to yourself or how did you
channel
something to say? To just
keep going --
People look at my life
, I was talking to my niece who
was is
in the audience, people
look at my life and say, she's
had it all
all,
oh, she's -- it's not the truth
. It's not where any of us
are. It's not what has
happened to any of us.
Yeah, I dealt with some really
rough times in my early
childhood, in my middle
childhood, and my teenage years,
and my
early adult life, and
work every time I have I
graduated high
school, never went to
College, and had to make a
decision -- I
actually got a scholarship,
an
scholarship ats a state
University
University, but also an
offer to sing on the road for
$600 a week
week,
working at a pizza parlor to
earn my way or I went the
singing and -- singing on
the road and the girl singer in
the
band. And making these
decisions all along the way
where you can
go a lot of different ways.
And I was pretty clear on what
I want
wanted to do. And it wasn't
easy.
But there were a lot
harder times than that where you
think
everything is down, down,
down on you.
And the world is crash
ing in on your soul. And I think
the
most important
thing I learn suicide that I
didn't have to do it
alone.
I thought I did. And I
thought I was -- family broke
up
early in my life -- and I
just kind of -- I was out there
and I
never -- I didn't go asking
for help or for
help and
-- and you
need to do that -- you need
to ask your teachers for
instruction,
if you're not following --
your homework -- sometimes your
children are not doing
their homework because they
don't know how
to do it.
They don't know how to
organize themselves, sometime
that's
the reason. Both my
children had learning disability
ies, genius IQ
IQ's but fell off the map,
one in math and one in reading.
I was
able to figure that out
when they were very small, and
got them
some extra help.
They were, you know,
they were so frustrated. And
they felt
stupid.
And I'm sure they got
that from me, the A DD bit or
the
whatever it was.
And they're both
graduateing law school now and
are very
successful, but we had to
retrain their brains doing
certain
things but getting through
it is part of it, you guys.
That's
part of it. It's step one
foot in front of the other.
Stepping
through it. It helps to
train your brain on how to do
the next
step, and how you do the
next step and I figured if this
doesn't
work this will and if this
doesn't then this will, if this
doesn't then this will, if
this doesn't then this will, and
ask
for help if you need it,
and I learn that lesson and I've
been in
recovery by the way for 20
years.
I'm telling you we're going to
fireed up and ready to go
after this.
This is something --
this is a very shameful thing,
you know
know, it's a shameful thing
to come to terms with. I can do
me. How could something like
that get
me. I didn't even drink in
my mid-twentyies -- it's genetic
you know -- as soon as I started
get
drinking to get rid of
feelings -- so -- and you feel
so, so, so
ashameed. I don't talk
about that much but I'm not
afraid to talk
about it either.
It's part of being a
grown up.
It's also part --
It's also part of being wonder
woman. Yeah.
Because what you have
just said and that's why I said
we'll
be fireed up and ready to
go is that everybody has that
spirit and
that wonder woman and you
have inspireed so many people
for so
long and we're just so
pleased that you can be with us
here today
today. I know I'm going to
really -- I shouldn't say this
-- what
what? Kick put next week?
You're wonderful.
So thank you so much.
I like that you wear flats, I
mean, I
like heals but -- yeah,
I've got my kitten heals in the
back, I'm
putting it on. I had to
step it up with you being here
you must
no, I had to do it. You
know I've been taking over the
whole --
they told me this is going
to be 15 minutes -- see? I knew
they
were lying.
So we have some people
that are really anxious to ask
some
questions and we have two
people one of both aisles with
the
microphone so -- that's a
-- I have to gain my exposure --
I'm
extremely exciteed to be
here -- I have a comment to tell
you --
my son, passed away a few
years ago, he was a Batman
fee thattic
and I'm a wonder woman fee
thattic, and the last memory I
have
from him, it brings you
strength, I went to Star Bucks,
you can
be whoever you want to be,
so one day I'm Lynda and one day
I'm
Diana and a lot of times
I'm wonder woman,.
>> » (APPLAUSE): , and
we went into Star Bucks and I
had to
use the restroom and I said
I ordered his drink and my
drink and
I said wonder woman and
Batman's drink is coming and
he's like
are you serious mom, and
I'm like yeah. He had both of
our drinks
and it was wonder woman and
Batman and it's one of my
memories we
have I wanted to tell you
thank you so much from the
bottom of my
heart. I love you so, so
much. I traveled far to be here
just to
be this close to you and
you inspire me and you inspire
my niece,
my family back home -- come
here.
Look at you.
Two part question -- first part
is light hearted. I know
you're an avid roller, I
wonder if you have an invisible
boat
because I've looked for you
and I can't find you? I have
not web
been rolling this year yet
but I belong to Potomac
boat club and
tomorrow some, so I gave my
faster rolling boat to the --
to the
girl that's are in the o
lymph pig rolling group of --
they're row
rowing for practicing for
the Olympics, it's a single, and
it was
too fast for me.
And I have my
at Thompson's -- as a matter of
fact, I'm
going to get back on the
river. Yeah. Yes.
It's called telling -- it's that
really cool looking thing
you see in the Olympics,
very long and shriek -- it's tip
py, if
you do it wrong you're
right in the water.
The second part is you
look amazing -- I am wondering
what
you do to look so great.
Thank you, I love you.
I think we have another one. I
work on it all the time.
You have no idea the
pressure.
From my daughter -- mom, why
aren't you working out. Holy
crap.
Hi. Hi. My daughter is
a lawyer who is studying for
the bar.
I said are you in the bar
or studying for the bar?
She's probably both.
So, hi my name is aida
, I work across the street this
year,
in my normal job I work for
the department of difference
where I
get to travel all over help
ing people and the like so we
can live
a better lifestyle. But
part of it was traveling to Iraq
and
Afghanistan and in Jordan
and I get to interact with women
who
don't have the same
opportunities that we do here.
And I wear
wonder woman everywhere I
go.
You're in
the military? No. They have a
height/weight
requirement, no. But in
every country I went the women
would come
to me on the side and say I
love wonder woman I want to be
wonder
woman. Just thank you
because I always wanted to be
wonder woman
too and to them I was help
ing them to be wonder woman. Oh.
Oh.
Thank you.
>> »
(APPLAUSE): .
You know, there's -- I really do
enjoy hearing the stories
and I always have. Many
actresses or actors they want to
divorce
themselves from a role
because we are actors, we really
aren't
the people that we play.
But -- I knew very
early on this character is much
more than
me certainly, and to try to
divorce myself from the
experience
that's other people have as
a character is silly. Truthful
ly, and
my family experiences it as
well. The stories that I hear
from
people are always so --
it's so much fun for me to hear
and to
look at the glimmer in the
eyes of parents that tell me
about the
children or people that
tell me about their own
experiences,
about feelings that they
have about themselves, or the
little
plaque that's someone has
given them for their work -- the
symbol
symbolism about overcomeing
things, you know, tragedyies or
admiration that someone has for
a certain
woman, this is all part of
the -- of the sisterhood, it's
all
part of the idea of wonder
woman, and I -- it's you, it's
you and
me, it's you and me and
Patty and gal, it's all of us.
And that
is where some people miss
the boat. On -- on this
character. Yes,
it's a comic book, I mean,
we're not stupid -- you know,
but
there is something deeper,
there is -- there is something
more
about -- about this -- it's
not an ideal of a woman, it's
about
her intellect, it's about
her character, and that's what
lives in
us.
And you too.
>> »
(APPLAUSE): .
We have time for one
more question. I want to thank
you so
much for your career and
inspirations, growing up with
you was
awesome and I know you're
ethnic heritage is Latina?
Uh-huh.
And I have my son
wonder woman doll, I took it
back when he
got older, how did growing
up Latina influence your life? I
was
-- the question is about
growing up in a Latina
family, my
grandmother was -- came
over as an infant from Mexico
and it was
a very rich heritage --
it's -- those of you -- any kind
of Eds
in this case family that is
a lot of food and music and
interactions and all of
that, that's what it meant to me
and it
was a lot of fighting, a
lot -- you know, a lot of
that malLee
making and torteea making
and it was really wonderful and
I -- my
memories are very rich in
that regard.
I wish that my own
children had had some of that,
which they
didn't because we liveed on
the East coast but I'm still in
touch
with many of my cousins
over the years and you know, I
have
an
understanding of the
immigrant
experience and I have an
understanding of being with
my
cousins
my -- my mother came from
a family of ten and in
those days in my town where my
grandmother
was from, her first husband
died and the second husband had
that came after had darker skin
so
the cousins and that had
darker skin and we would be
together,
and I experienceed this --
this racism and hatred of others
-- the
other -- and it was so
confusing to me. It was so
unfair, it was
--
my grandmother would ask me to
take something, return
something, at the store and
I said why doesn't he do it and
she
would say because they
won't take it from him.
I would take it back
and they would take it from me.
And they wouldn't take
the return from the darker skin
cousin.
And you know,
it hurts new a a place that
hurts you in some
raw place that unless
you've experienceed it you don't
understand.
Personally did I experience
? My children are Jewish, so
how far
-- how many steps removeed
are we from pilgrims
of Europe and you
know. People I can't think
ing people off of streets like
is
happening with ICE right
now. It's scary stuff. So anyway
, that
is my Latina experience and
most of it is absolutely grow
ing it
and I loveed it. That's
what I take from it -- a great
amount of
understand
understanding and love for
hard-working immigrant families.
Well, I know they told you 15
minutes and we have kept you a
lot longer, they never said
15 minutes -- but before we end
we
just wanted to give you
something that we hope that you
will know
comes from us with deep
gratitude -- do I get to give
you
something first? Oh, well
now that's good. Oh, and it's
behind --
the TV -- where's the other
thing? Oh, there's more? Yeah,
where
where's -- we better get
some more stuff on our side --
oh my
goodness -- this is --
where's my little note?
Right here. Show
them. This is an original
issue of wonder woman 77, number
one,
it's the original number
one.
And everyone is seeing me accept
this for the library right?
And this is an original
illustration by the artist cat
sags,
one of the contributing art
ist of the comic book series,
she
completed this piece of art
specifically for this event,
it's one
of a kind and it won't be
reproduceed from the DC comic
world. I
want it. I want it.
>> »
(APPLAUSE): .
Don't worry, you won't see this
in my office.
Hey,. This is very
cool. This is so cool. You can't
believe
how cool this is.
From the director
Patty Jenkins,
to Dr. Hayden and friends
of the library of Congress
are, on behalf of all of us that
made
this film, Warner bros and
DC comics we're so incredibly
honored
to have a copy of our
script presented here today.
>> » (APPLAUSE): .
Wow. Wow.
Comic books and superheros are
uniquely successful
American, American
phenomena that can at times
symbolize the best
the United States of
America has to offer.
With this film we inspireed to
live up to the highest hopes
anti-deals of both art
forms, it is a particularly -- a
housed here among so many other
great
treasures of our great
nation. I truly wish that I
could be
thereto stand side by side
with the great ambassador of all
things wonder woman.
But we are all there in spirit
and wish you great success
and celebration of a great
and unique medium. With
gratitude
Patty Jenkins. Wow. Wow. Oh
my God. The original wonder
woman
script. Wow. Wow.
This is something.
Isn't that great? I'm sorry.
And it is truly a
thrill for when I first had
contact with
them Patty wanted to be
here, when I first contacted her
, to do
this, they were -- they
were so thrilled because of this
great
institution, and everyone
of you take this -- take this
time,
take this adventure, take
this with you and share it with
friends
and go online, and become a
part -- I ask you personally to
family, of the library of
Congress. Because
it is -- it is for you --
it is for our nation, it is the
greatest gift to
honor your curiosity for the
ages, and there is
no other library of its
kind in the world.
>> » (APPLAUSE):
I'm truly, truly -- there is no
other
library of its kind.
In the world, and
its Stewart is the first woman,
the first
woman of color, the first
person of color our wonderful
Carla
Hayden.
I tell you.
Well, the gifts you have given
us are indescribeable -- she's
so cool. We just wanted to
give you something -- this is a
copy
of the first appearance of
wonder woman frozennization
comics and
this is in the library's
collection and it's on display
but we
wanted you to have this for
yourself, and it says in deep
appreciationation presented
to Lynda Carter with -- I can't
even
say -- how much we
appreciate you being here and
giving us all in
inspir ration. We really,
really thank you. And I'm
telling you,
-- we had fun. We had fun.
And we should know that my
wonder
woman thing here, I'm
putting it on the door. Thank
you all of
you. We really appreciate
it.
>> »
(APPLAUSE): .
Look at that.
Take a bough.
>> » (APPLAUSE): .
You can visit the exhibit. The
library of awesome is here
through tomorrow and we are
going to see maybe we can put
the
script on display. So we
would love for you to see it, so
we're
going to do that. We thank
all of you. Thank you
you good friends
for this library. Thank you
to all of you.
>> » (APPLAUSE): .
Donate
5-cents,
5-dollar, one dollar.
Whatever you can.
>> »
(APPLAUSE): .